citizens of the reject Nation how are
you you lovelies it is time for another
installment of we didn't have a
childhood full of DC animated films who
are making up for it now and people
think in the comments that we have
already seen them and we're like no we
haven't did these comments make no sense
why are we reacting to something
surprising guessing things wrong if
we've already seen them the series and
we hope you're enjoying it please do
like subscribe hit that notification
Bell let us know which one of these you
want to watch next because you may have
noticed last week last episode last time
we concluded the dcam you hey how you
feeling about today's I am excited to go
into areas Uncharted koi we're going
back in time back into the past so to
well-charted territory for others
Uncharted for me that's how 2010 feels
2023 old very long ago also speaking of
old the opposite of that new shirts we
got a bad first shirt it's got three
Batman some might say the best three
Batman you can argue in the comments I
think Christian Bale might be on that
shirt next time but batford shirt is
available right now at our shop
subzeroedition.com
and
this summer
coming soon to a Comic Con near you the
real rejects we're gonna be there
Saturday the 22nd more details to come
but if you're there on Saturday look for
these Rejects and alas foreign
are you a patron are you sexy have you
joined the sexiest Nation the reject
nation of the sexiest caliber because
you should because that's how you watch
this whole thing front to back begin and
with our resting faces
and only the patrons get that experience
so get on over there and join us and
without further Ado this is 2010's
Justice League crisis on how many Earths
just the two just the two
I didn't drive back then yet I know I
was gonna say we're not opening up with
a Chase or a you know any transportation
Metropolitan Street
is this the same clown guy from a few
movies ago in the AMU continuity it must
be because I don't think Joker has ever
been quite the jester he is here the
quantum trigger now we have a chance
Quantum that's timey why me
I was gonna say we're gonna get that
2010 animation flavor too yeah see how
things have changed
[Music]
I'm getting named him I might not have
realized that's like Lex Luthor guessed
that first yeah unless in this universe
they're good guys and the Justice
League's bad could be it's time to get
seriously no we can make it together we
can do this that's your shiny bald head
out of here it's hurting my eyes
oh
[Music]
what can I say
dang just murdered
okay okay
I'm down to my last joke anyway I guess
it must be the joke but this one will
kill you
[Music]
whoa Luthor oh this is so fun oh it is
that they're the bad guys Ultra Man
owl over there Earth two you'll get a
pie for what you've done mate I'm going
to finish the job the jester started
I was right the first time
dude he's got goth eyeliner that means
he's very evil he is dramatic he has
seen some stuff Sinister raised by Mom
pocket somewhere not in Kansas
Billy Baldwin in Philly
the darkness of Philadelphia Mark Harmon
multiversal content topical I know right
and Now's the Time while everyone's
exhausted we should watch this while
everyone's seen a lot of it don't worry
in every other Universe we're watching a
singular timeline fair fair
I love this this is great scope of it
[Music]
yeah the Batman man a good opening
titles is underrated it really is it
brings you in
hey Josh Keaton's in this we were just
talking about hey
Spider-Man himself
Nolan North I love Nolan and I love this
too like giving us the hint of like okay
here's who's who yeah I like that too
dang cool
do you think they're going to argue over
which is Earth one
all right flash beginning test run
you're absolutely sure it works pretty
sure pretty sure
there's even a one percentage good
enough cool teleporters online
[Laughter]
fat carbs
no need to make a scene I want you to
contact the Justice League for me or
else I'll destroy the world is that
sufficient
uh
it's up down here
[Music]
yes oh and they call me the Flash
you're going to find what I have to say
very difficult to believe you're from a
parallel Earth your internal organs are
reversed your heart is on the wrong side
wowie thank you Mark Harmon Superman but
our Luther is still in his cell on
Striker's Island and now that we've
clarified the matter of my evil twin
story to tell you pants
turns out I was armed after
I call them little Lex oh I'm not just
the leader of my world's Justice League
I'm its only surviving member we were
systematically destroyed by a group of
super-powered beings known as the crime
syndicate in the hope of maintaining
some minimal order the authorities
simply pretend they aren't there but
increasingly they refuse to be ignored
well yeah you people are my World's Last
Hope we have to discuss this please wait
out here your call is very important to
us
it's another thing that is sort of
surprisingly become a favorite beat I
love twists on Lex
[Music]
and of course willing to help she's
right that's what we do
not this time oh but we're talking about
millions of people we can't just turn
our backs we have to go what if you
split up Batman you go build stuff we're
gonna go save the rest of us will take
care of this all right we'll help but we
need a plan I have one of course wait is
that what's happening because Batman
just
it sort of seems like it
I was joking Batman what are you doing
he's gonna have to save him though once
they get trapped he's gonna be standing
here back grumbling I'm gonna bat brood
over this new building
Earth City
staring out of the globe
any sign of the quantum trigger if it
was here it's not now download all these
records into my personal computer
's place of anything useful then destroy
it God even like the choice in the
different voices is interesting I like
the overhead smash people are moving
orienting but there are no other side
effects that
what the hell we're compromised was this
the plan yeah
ow that'll be enough of that
oh it's a level Superman damn
[Music]
you like a knockoff static shock it's
not going good for him
ice
[Music]
that animation yeah
[Laughter]
this is Marvel
slap in the basement
That's What I Call tuning somebody up
that's awesome
can I talk to you for a minute always
don't fall for Flash
I am 10 times the King was
that's the crossover we're waiting for
yeah oh no oh no now we're cocaine bear
oh
babe that bear Fame the bear
ouch
whoa turn into a rocket beat scissors
well done sir thank you thank you that's
how you know you know your Comics we're
in it we were ready you want to help me
I don't want to fight you I want it
hey this is like the Jedi mind trick
that's a Disney property flash yeah
dude I feel like not in a while the
super breath Superwoman's called in the
Cavalry at least three made men almost
as tough as Superwoman made men
[Music]
oh crap
guys can't fly really you can't like
flap his legs fast enough to tell
himself upward
God what a great shot of Superman coming
up yeah
it's funny because it's not that old but
it does have a sort of classic kind of
feel to it the weight of them flying
feels different yeah this is something
with like the motion quality yeah well I
think it's more hand-drawn
play
[Laughter]
nicely done barrels
what was that Black Adam is that black
Adam see a maid man
whoa
it's having a Black Adam vibes
laughs
yeah Diana of that too with the claw
marks
or I guess are they all like this Black
Adam de facto kryptonians for this
universe oh that's interesting oh they
seem to have lightning abilities
definitely a Black Adam wardrobe yeah
for sure
I love that they also look like an
old-timey like villain yeah like
villains but also like magic show act or
something like yeah they have like a
like a vaudevillian yeah that kind of
burlesque show sort of quality
that's it sweet
[Music]
I was wondering about that yeah we got
to decide who we're calling up to
replace jarcus Brooklyn Superman
over here a grown mom parking Brooklyn
I'm a mad man begun construction on this
the quantum eigenstate device once
completed the QED will give us life and
death power over the entire planet
dangle that knife the device is
Heisenberg uncertainty override allows
us to tap into a limitless pool of
destructive energy
we don't have the power to fight them
might doesn't
in the long run it's the other way
around we are always stronger when we're
doing the right thing
preach yeah I like that and it's good
she's even got a little slogan yeah the
Rhymes I remember
it doesn't make right
Birds of Prey very much
it's not mine it used to belong to a
friend oh R.I.P Jester we hardly knew
you not the same guy but sort of kind of
the same guy The Joker
the gesture is never coming back oh
Harley's a monkey
each of the family heads have thousands
of criminals working under them they
reward their most trusted lieutenants oh
[__] oh Mr Miracles some sort of and it
was a cyborg it was a Zatanna stand in
no more than seven or eight at a time
perhaps fifty
uh we're going to hit multiple targets
at the same time of course we'd be
hopelessly outnumbered when my Justice
League fought them we aren't your
Justice League yeah
flashed and boomerang
Matrix cast member and yellow guy hey
and Taxi Driver Lobo from the 80s Lobo
Mobo
confidential
[Music]
the shipment of torpedo well this is
awkward that was confidential
speedy
red and Rosie just red arrow because he
looks adult Speedy I think of his young
Sea Beast
amazing
it's cool that manhunter's actually
getting like a a featured fight here
doing stuff and using his abilities in
creative ways yeah right then Abandoned
Ship if you can if you can
sorry Lobo
it's good use of like weight and scale
for that yeah and I love all the power
used so far
[Music]
oh
clever nicely done and nicely animated
Ultraman I know you can hear me
Jimmy Olsen whoa he ain't here you want
an appointment you can call his
secretary clear our airspace the name is
ladies yeah 100 boxes of Wheaties a day
I got the big guy oh yes they got they
dropped the pal
I'd rather not have to hurt you Jimmy of
course
it's gonna hurt me more than hurts you
oh to call Ultraman get your hands off
my boy you got problems of your own my
boy
he Lex yeah especially if you can't kill
like you do have to take him out on your
own I'm here because I'm the baddest of
the bad anybody who ever stood in my way
is dead everybody
woof Kryptonite the only thing that can
hurt you
damn destroyed the last piece on Earth
true but I've been visiting other Earths
Planet Jersey
things are changing when you do wrong
there are more and more of us who aren't
afraid to set it right yeah
beautiful oh that guy the background
look at the triumphs yay we're not dead
this is unacceptable Lex what do you
think you're doing oh no that should be
obvious Mr President a Deathstroke yeah
I was gonna say I've already ordered the
release of Ultraman wow I'm sorry Mr
President but we're not about to give up
this fight not when we finally have a
chance to win it
poor president Slade Wilson
no respect aren't you supposed to be
helping I am helping I'm improving the
Ambiance
having to use that that's a great line
somewhere in the Multiverse there is a
world I call Earth Prime the original
and once I destroy it all reality will
follow
you got a real death wish man it just
cumulative don't get in my way to the
contrary
but but that too I just amen
this is not gonna end well it was
nihilists I mean he's gonna he's gonna
shove you off this train at some point
it's coming you get your little girl
under control remember what happened to
the first lady if you come near my
daughter I will nuke you great equalizer
huh
whoa whoa that was that was a backhand
of Justice yeah seriously I felt that
Luther took the quantum trigger to a
parallel birth would you be a deer pop
over to the universe next door and pick
it up for me
perimeter breach potential Intruder
Alert
see he planned to have he knew someone
needed to stay behind so in the lookout
[__] was a foot
oh Batman entrance
whoa whoa power loader Batman
you're on my
back off before I come over there and
hurt you get away from my property you
[__]
and Neo back in oh beautiful also Bruce
Lee a lot of people but NEOS who I love
people back in just saying it's a good
backing
your face
stay down here I'm numbered count again
[Music]
oh yeah what
you guys are in trouble be up take them
[Music]
you just bring them here from Earth yeah
he's just that was a teleporter he's
just popping him in
hot man come on mullet Aquaman
I'm here for it it's good
so black and arrow I think that's an is
that static shock like as an adult who's
that guy
[Music]
oh not bad
oh yeah nice get him firestorm
is going to be tougher than I thought
nah you got this man even down one floor
wanna hear secrets
jeez
I was never gonna hear again
Alex expensive stayed behind to fix all
this up I'm just trashing his
teleportation
yeah
deserve power
oh dang
static shocked
[Music]
that's right
you've got possibilities little man
you gotta type
that lip bites the lip bite you're right
she definitely has a type such a great
little flourishes in the animations
where else is yeah I agreed like that
stuff you take the time to do right
that's someone drawing oh we got
teleported dang joining me today are
elected officials who aren't afraid to
act
together we can win together
whoa excuse me well done arson man
answer excuse me Jeremy John's holding
him down
how's that working out for you guys stay
away from me maybe two will work
those are some nice boots though cool
[Music]
I'll continue to keep close watch on you
until the immediate crisis has passed
that'd be just fine
nice moves you remind me of my boyfriend
[Laughter]
look how casual she is about destroying
her own stuff too that's power perhaps a
fear an Earth where Humanity has mutated
into hideous creatures of the night
Cronenberg the world you might like that
or it might be fun to keep you as a pet
your call sorry you're not my type dang
that's going to cost you a rib
[Music]
with a thumb just a press damn Adam and
Eve with a smoke bomb
[Music]
at lung capacity it's not smoke
tonight
oh no it's anesthetic gas
ah smart man well done
what's up
it's two of those
I'm on your Earth I figured out the S
stands for Sato masochism
what did you hide on my satellite I
don't know what you're talking about
it's the quantum trigger the Detonator
for a bomb they're building why didn't
you just destroy it it's pure energy it
can't be destroyed also Fair they could
use it to set off an explosion that
would wipe out the entire Earth you
think too small yeah I was gonna say
mustn't be afraid to dream a little
bigger darling yeah skating cascading
cascading sorry to come in without
permission but Superwoman said to bring
this right to you she is
[Music]
our minds are in sync to a degree that
was rare even among my own people I
never imagined I'd meet a human so
complementary to myself I feel it
oh
trying to kiss you a way of sharing
affection this is
Mars
oh my
God where are we going are we getting
some Navi hair tendrils what's happening
oh it's like a lovely stare oh
[Music]
oh they're like bonding through memory
and like shared happiness
oh maybe not all happens
but yeah like the minds think bonding
deeply the good and the bad
[Music]
wow I love that they're actually
spotlighting him in this yeah wow
we know each other huh that's great do
you really think you can beat the crime
syndicate if we could find them I could
find out where their base is my father's
known for Years also could we actually
kiss I mean that's that was on my end
that was beautiful
kissing is very much more simple
this this makes the physical just you
know boost of superpowers look very fun
yeah I agreed it's like man I would be
so handy
this is one of the ones that feels the
most like a movie yeah not like a long
episode or something it feels very
cinematic and real
how are we supposed to get in again
multi-frequency band encryption analyzer
replicator pack some of us don't speak
Star Trek
is it just me
no we're fine yeah sure that's never
happened before we've got the bomb
everybody does what we say or else
you're bluffing as long as the bomb's
here all you can blow up is your own
house
laughs
and now the odds are six to three count
again
look who I found in the hangar
damn it
ah clever
God the sound effects yeah
[Music]
not the good pairing nope get out of
that bats can we get everybody with
their counterparts please
cool use a mirror like reflection
there it is yes okay the order has been
restored evil Batman versus Batman
excellent
on the way just to drive by punch
red and yellow blurs yeah
cool I like the choreography on the fist
fights too yeah and the like the motion
and the physics and stuff like whoa
they're actually like fighting feels
like a wrestling match
[Music]
oh fun
no
all right what you got Lex
I always get Batman fighting on a
catwalk Bridge loves them
I guess that's where a bat would hang
out and an owl that's where he birthed
as Nemesis is on uh over a vat of acid
we found it
is it the real Earth Prime 52 do they
all claim to be Earth Prime he's taking
the QED to Earth Prime if he detonates
it he'll destroy all reality oh man's
just taking the bomb to a hiding place
don't try and con me what are you two
doing we're on our Natural Born Killers
[__]
and it's does this thing keep in its
memory the last dozen or so but that's
more than enough oh
this is a good device I like this device
it's got just enough memory it's
practical
locked out
unless
someone vibrating at the right speed
could piggyback on all man's carrier
wave and open a portal but he'd have to
be fast barreled
no you're not you're too slow what I
know your limitations you can't possibly
reach the speed necessary to pull this
off
ouch dude
ouch he's talking about blowing up my
world too and I'm not letting that
happen it could be dangerous the bloody
universe is at stake of course it's
dangerous
fair damn he's really faster than flash
flash
ouch you have to hold that speed
precisely
oh no treadmill required
come on
oh cool wow nice
hold that speed damn
[Music]
enter the speed force go Batman
no hesitation
those primes not looking so good
I can't imagine what series of decisions
led to this world hurtling out of its
orbit but I know this the source of the
cataclysm was the same as it always is
man huh always you're insane how does it
really matter there are alternate
versions of me that you would find quite
Charming
yep
oh
I gotta say this is a pretty interesting
Wasteland very your attitude your
costume your tactics they all scream of
outrage oh what terrible wrong was done
to set you on this path you forgot
Justin
what are you planning to do talk me to
death
I thought I'd get you to death
hey
what does that say about your attackers
damn it
and you could learn a thing or two from
now man cover that mouth
that Manning you must have been a good
man once never good after all I'm only
human
ouch
oh nice
all that math there is a difference
between you and me
I'm not wearing hockey pants yes
that is a bar nicely done that cold
Planet I'm guessing because he saved it
yeah nice
oh die all alone little man
[Music]
it doesn't matter
it was keeping it real to the very end
oh man oh it doesn't matter
beautiful nihilism and yeah like I've
seen so many Wasteland climaxes but
these wastelands were super interesting
too yeah heavy metals sci-fi concept art
yeah
oh look at that man
Johnny I'm back stop vibrating oh God
oh wow time dilation he just saved
infinite Earths yeah and what a cool
sort of compliment too it's a Flashpoint
in a way
did we save the world then
we did
and all that rubbish
me being faster than Flash
you knew this was gonna happen
always
a baby good one mate
oh you can't die you have a crypt to
keep
I kind of thought she used to deliver
man we need you that was clever
yeah that was good we almost lost
everything that was then now you're a
bunch of wannabe cops trying to take me
in I was 40 seconds ago this is now two
things you ain't got the authority and
you ain't nearly Tough Enough The
Authority we are more than Tough Enough
brought the Cavalry I brought the
Marines hit the view the proud
the Space Marines yes the space force
hey
Space Marines led by the president
himself that's right man showed up in
person it's that old school American
grit you know on the front lines I've
already ordered the National Guard to
support local law enforcement teams
we're rounding up the bad guys
everywhere
oh I don't want you to go but I don't
belong here
you could I don't belong here excuse me
John but would you stop acting like an
idiot this is what we fight for
if you love her stay
I mean we can always come visit you
she's already lost I mean you've already
lost your world standards I've already
lost one home I made a promise to
protect my new one oh then this is how
we say goodbye oh that's why they didn't
kiss before we saved it give momona
Diana dang beautiful
maybe there's another one like her back
on our Earth with my luck she'll be evil
[Applause]
forever
I mean that's that's kind of beautiful
but also like damn
that's good to be back home
mind your head
oh that's great
you can fly you drive a car what do you
do Jeff where you can fly you drive a
car genius explanation more help around
here wouldn't be a bad idea I'm glad you
agree I've been thinking about a
membership Drive
ha
KP Justice League hey
that was so good I loved that oh my
goodness that was a delight and like it
literally did everything I wanted that
last Multiverse movie to do really was
James Woods oh yeah no I wasn't kidding
Josh Keaton crushed his Flash
all the voices
James Patrick Stewart who's a different
guy different Patrick Stewart yeah oh
and Bruce Tim was Uncle super I love it
damn yeah that was so incredible I loved
his multiversal explanation I loved how
cinematic it felt I love that it did the
thing where it made you invested in both
sets of Worlds see this is the thing you
do it right right now is is a time where
we're hearing two things I think a lot
which is ah man that Superhero fatigue
and ah man that Multiverse fatigue is
almost I said in the beginning but like
the thing is when you each time you see
one that's done well it doesn't matter
right like and and yeah like watching
this at a time where we have like a new
adaptation of Flashpoint we have like a
bunch of other multiversal stories you
know dominating the multiplex probably
more to come like this felt so like I
wasn't thinking about any of that I was
just sucked into this and like it was
that's why I like I think Deadpool kills
the fox universe is come like I
predicted eight years ago and I think if
they do it right it won't be fatigue I
hope not you know what I mean because
like I I assume it's going to be what we
wanted Multiverse of Madness to be if my
assessment of what I think they should
do but I think that we won't be sick of
it like I think if they do it right it's
good like this this was an hour and 16
minutes I know this was better than any
Justice League movie I've seen in live
action and it sweeps you up in the
adventure and in the immediacy and it
also has an interesting take on what its
version of the Multiverse is how it is
used and represented and I mean here
this is an example of something where we
don't like hop to a million universes
only two couple other ones others are
alluded to but we're mainly just on
these Two Earths even the credits look
at the inverse credit and then the world
spinning in different directions
different like pangeas like it's genius
even the credits are insightful yes like
I like this is It's funny this came out
in 2010 because this to me does feel
like a great combo of like it it feels
classic and like to something that would
have fallen out of like the height of
the animated DC Series in the 90s or
something like that in terms of like the
craftsmanship and like no shade to the
DC AMU stuff we've been watching in the
more modern stuff but there is something
that feels a bit more tangible in the
animation yeah and the nuances of motion
and the little ticks and mannerisms they
give all the characters that are then
combined with the voices and like this
was given me like the best of like what
I love and and sort of get nostalgic for
about like you know the animated shows
that I have seen but also things like I
don't know like Parts this had like a
watch mini kind of yeah I mean yeah
Alamance certainly like feeling like a
mix of like I mean less night out and
more kind of a doctor Manhattan yeah
more Shack Thing by the end like if you
smash those two together because yeah
this whole nihilistic view on everything
and yeah being like the polar opposite
of of Bruce himself and yeah and Ultra
man being such a good antithesis to
Superman and in really different ways
yeah didn't feel too much like uh your
traditional like red Sun or too much
like even homelander he felt like his
own different thing that was still the
opposite because of how archetypal these
characters are yeah and like it's funny
that they are like a mob and that they
have like you know hey like you know
he's kind of got that you know Brooklyn
kind of accent or whatever which is the
anti-kansas sure
and uh family and family yeah and then
and then what's uh I guess the the
opposite of Central City is just
Australia yeah there it is but but that
too a dense Metropolis or like the the
Down Under absolutely like like I I love
the tweaks and nuances and the way in
which like yeah you do have a certain
amount of like part versus counterpart
but I thought yeah the way that they
drew the characters and I don't know how
faithful this is being to one particular
iteration of this in the comics I know
the name crisis on infinite Earth sure
um but yeah just like the way it
realized each of these different
characters it just sort of let you I
think the opening credit scene was
really nicely hewned to you know show
you who is who and who is whose
counterparts yeah um but yeah just like
the way they realize those characters
and the way they cast the voices to play
off of you know the voices of the main
Justice League we are used to like this
this is just one of those experiences
where like every element felt like it
had a lot of care and you know uh
inspiration put on it you know the
production was incredible top to bottom
I mean we talked about the choreography
we talked about the weight in the fights
we talked about the sound design we
talked about the score we talked about
the opening credits like when you look
at a movies assemblage it is so many
pieces that's why I personally think
seeing movies in theaters is so
important because you need to show your
support for the thousands of people that
are involved because I mean the best boy
does more work than people give credit
for there's every element of these
movies in this one we noticed we noticed
the care in the sound design we noticed
the care in how the fights felt like
certain Styles we noticed the care in
the characterization so the writing was
top-nosis the directing like this felt
like it had weight like a classic
animated movie where like the hand-drawn
frames allow it to feel like something
instead of just like like if you skip
steps you feel it and whether you notice
why you feel it's kind of like The
Uncanny Valley like if you're looking at
something that's like that almost feels
human but something's off sometimes
animation does that for me and I I've
been very public about like my
disconnect from animation these movies
have really helped me connect to the
animation differently spider-verse is
probably the thing that's helped me most
the animation the first one and the new
one but I don't consider animation
um a lesser medium a lot of people do I
think incorrectly I've been to West it
gets sideways that is a thing for kids
and and I don't think that's true and I
never have even when I haven't connected
to it but I have started to connect more
with it through things like this and
through movies that have the weight
because I realize that like I was
judging my connection on weak links
because of like you know my my seeing
certain things and now that I'm seeing
things of quality it's been really
helping my connection to the entire
medium that is animation and this was
one of the better Justice League things
I've seen hard stop yeah right like it
was really good and this had again for
for my money money this had kind of
everything you would hope for out of
both a big event you know a big
particularly cataclysmic you know event
storyline like this but also just you
know a comic like it has a certain
amount of you know actual implications
and debate and they go see the president
and they're you know they're like great
philosophical the implication of like
what is our jurisdiction here like you
know who can we afford to be worried
about right now when we got our own
problems
die because of these oppressors yeah and
it's like they have those kinds of
things going on but it's not bogged down
and being like a philosophical
rumination or being like way more
serious than it needs to it's got fun
but all that stuff's in character and
it's not like too jokey like the the
humorous bits feel uh appropriate to
each character and like that whole thing
at the end where it's like oh man he's
like it doesn't matter you know it's so
impressive for the punchline is like the
perfect flip side to the darkness you
associate with with nihilism and like
yeah and yeah it has things that feel
like Saturday morning cartoons Justice
League but that also sit right next to
stuff that again feels like you're
peering into like a Alan Moore version
of a Justice League story and do the
juxtaposition of every character we've
mentioned a couple times but I love the
Batman everything matters ending with l
man's nothing matters yeah and I love
that you know Superwoman kind of
juxtaposing Wonder Woman in a really
interesting way because she's all about
conquering whereas Wonder Woman's all
about giving and good like they did such
a good job in dialogue as well as action
going like we know these characters so
well yeah and and this is what I'm
talking about with archetypal characters
being uh so multifaceted because we I
remember we watched Injustice and we
enjoyed it because we weren't as
connected to the comics I've read the
first two volumes but not the Myriad of
volumes and like I had a good time
because it understood the archetypes of
the characters I see this I think did
even better because when I talk about
how good Superman is this shows how bad
he can be without it sacrificing how
good he is yeah exactly and I mean even
like it took me a minute to kind of you
know like Mark Harmon Superman man is a
bit more like he's not as warm and
custody he's not warm at all it's
interesting I struggled a little bit in
the beginning yeah yeah but I thought at
least his resolve and his like true
Comfort yeah his heart and Compass I
thought worked really nicely and I mean
yeah you don't really do anything with
Lowe's you don't really see into his
life but I one thing we've also talked
about which I thought I was like joking
about at first but then they actually
dignified with a with Great Moments was
the whole like potential little romance
nugget with uh Jon Jones oh that was a
potential that was acted on that was
love no yeah I was like I bet she she
seems kind of into him and then they
actually like mine and they did the Mind
meld and we got a little bit of a deep
dive into his backstory for a minute and
most people have seen of him and and I
mean yeah and it is kind of a fun meme
of like Hawkman and Martian Manhunter
like they're always here especially
throughout the DC AMU but like
boy did they they get maybe one line at
best and here I was like oh cool and and
I know people complain of like ah you
know he's pretty similar to Superman
plus a couple other little things but I
I love the way they used him here yeah I
really enjoyed his character here and I
really like that every small character
got enough a moment that I was invested
in them like I cared about her care
about her journey cared about her dad's
cared about all the stuff understood
where everyone was coming from
understood like you know the stakes of
the world yeah and I cared about
Batman's goals even though it juxtaposed
the Justice Leagues because where he was
coming from and like our Earth is so
good like yeah
dimensions and like how him leaving that
there and like why Lex would leave that
there and why they'd go looking for like
every step was genius yeah and starting
out yeah with like Lex and a de facto
Joker jester you know stand-in and this
bond between them like old friend the
last two of the Justice League of Their
worlds like such a beautifully like nice
little compelling way to pull you in and
make you go oh maybe the Justice League
is the villains in here like you pointed
out and then and what a great way to tie
you to the New Lex like what a great way
to like bring a naked Lex into this
planet and be funny and like make a good
opening it feels so cinematic it feels
like a movie and I love it and I and I
have James gonna watch this one yeah no
yes there's no way he hasn't seen this
visit please because yeah I love the way
that they uh you know I get I gather
that this is a frequent thing that
happens but twists on Lex where he like
you know ends up working with the good
guys always uh you know I get a big kick
out of that have you heard the latest
rumor about Lex no it's down to two
names play them Jesse Eisenberg and
Jonah Hill correct I heard it here first
who's it gonna be who's it potentially
Alexander Skarsgard
okay Bill Skarsgard it's not even
kidding it is down to scars guards just
as it was down I mean Liam grams were
Liam Neeson it was Liam Hemsworth or
Chris Hemsworth it is now bill or
Alexander skars making a real weird
Thanksgiving James again and Peter's
average is gonna walk into that audition
room and just like break that pool cue
in half
and then cast
and castellan
ah yes I'm absolutely perfect but I love
that a Skarsgard is likely going to be
Lex because I think either would crush
it and they're very different but also
very unnerving yeah yeah no I mean
nobody likes an occult for superman but
I did from the jump I just want Nicole
to get like in there the the Multiverse
man it is
to to see what all these choices make a
Superman movie I would do with the
Multiverse infinite Earth and and I
liked you know wrapping up I liked the
way that they portrayed and set up their
Multiverse what the reasoning was for
how and why it Orcs And That device that
Hopper I think is a really great it's
got slight limitations it feels tangible
in like how it navigates you're like oh
yeah I get how this machine works it's
not too mumbo jumbo yeah 12 or whatever
Place yeah members like it's got the
whole lexicon but it only remembers the
history to a certain point you know and
it's like compact like an old phone like
a T-Mobile yes great and uh and and I do
love the the with the Martian Manhunter
they left that with like
I believe there's a version of this
where he would stay but he makes the
Bolder choice to be like but no he's
committed to his Earth and as much as
this Bond you know would be something
worth staying for I I can't you know
it's like I can see people maybe arguing
over a beat like that but I that just I
don't know suggests the kind of well
every decision like I love that simple
element explanation of like there's one
where you do this when we do this and
that causes infinite Ripples and like
you could spend a lifetime looking for
the changes or it's kind of like that
explanation was genius yes oh this movie
was good so lovely yeah this is my top
third for sure this one uh this one's up
there that had a great time
um we are likely to be ranking the DC
AMU soon but uh when we rank the entire
DC uh animated Pantheon this one's gonna
be up there for sure oh I'm so happy
right now it's so good inspired and
joyous and that's what this was a true
joy and uh and yeah like I love I love
all animation but I love especially this
stuff where it's like you can feel the
flourishes man you can feel the art
loved it loved it excellent work I'm
gonna pick somebody to give some love to
on this excellent video absolutely let's
do a little patreon of the day shout out
let's get it
pandemic Jones my dude you got a good
Multiverse name pandemic I feel like you
know pandemic Jones across many
universes could be so many I mean
obviously there's one Universe where you
are like kind of a a corraller a wielder
of microbials and disease right actually
but you know I've always wondered like
why isn't there like a pandemic why
isn't there like a virus that you know
makes good things happen that could be
one of your worlds or uh you know in a
different world pandemic doesn't even
mean what it means here maybe
um it's just a bunch of actual pans and
they're just everywhere every four
lights I don't know what to do with all
this but then you can melt them down and
turn them into something else it's
called being resourceful pandemic you
know I would argue
Humanity
itself oh is the pandemic of positivity
when wielded correctly sure we replicate
rapidly we are are technically a virus
in the way that we ignore our
surroundings and we like we consume more
than we output but when we are a force
we can create so much goodness that it
does like every generation thinks it
allows generation because there's that
moment of like we've done it now but if
you look at like what we've we've been
able to accomplish like no other species
has left their planet to our knowledge
yet I'm sure they exist because I don't
believe that there can't be but I do
believe that in our our existence on our
Earth we are the only creation we know
that is spread to scale and we invented
language and we invented culture and we
invented these things and that's all as
a virus so I would say the pandemic that
you're speaking of that is that is a
good thing is Humanity which pandemic
Jones is part of and his last name being
Jones as I've mentioned another shout
out is one of those names like Smith
where it's a common last name
juxtaposing the first name so pandemic
Jones represents Humanity or the spread
it of humanity
Spirit of the spread of our of our
virtue of our best virtuous Endeavor yes
I think we can be a good virus this was
a peak shout out Cole you really took it
you really took my nonsense and turned
it into something put it together let's
put it together I just wanted to make
sure that's how I feel about that name
pandemic Jones is the spread of virtuous
good I mean if that doesn't inspire you
to stay pledged pandemic that's the tip
that's a negative Point all right in
every Universe you were pledged you
can't disrupt that order that's my
Superman speech I got nothing else I
can't I can't go higher okay you're good
for the day baby okay good that's it
it's not like that pandemic all the love
buddy we'll see you next time patrons
and everybody else much love
foreign